in the town of bala nassau there is a
line on the floor if you're on one side
of this line you're in the netherlands
with its fancy windmills
if you're on the other you're in belgium
with its convenient access for german
armor divisions
nowadays many a nation is easily
recognizable by its silhouette and
within the borders of a nation we can
easily determine who its people are and
all that good stuff
the obvious question is was it so clear
in the ancient or medieval world
let's say you're a roman peasant
congratulations during the reign of
emperor hadrian who ruled rome at its
greatest territorial extent
if you simply walked north from rome
when if ever would you know that you'd
left the roman empire
see rome is a good example when
discussing borders because it had a
centralized government a professional
army whose job it was to protect the
empire and also the romans had a good
sense of borders which they called limas
unsurprisingly much of rome's lima
stopped at natural barriers like
mountain ranges or perhaps most notably
the rhino danubian rivers
the border was sporadically lined with
watchtowers and wooden fortifications
where possible but this was a long
border and so naturally much of it was
unmarked the biggest exception to this
was of course
hadrian's wall maps like this make it
look like these areas were firmly in
rome's control
and that those outside were entirely
foreign to put it bluntly this simply
wasn't the case
there were settlements close to the
empire's borders who made quite a living
trading with rome and many of those
within the roman empire didn't really
see themselves as being roman
looking at you britannia so traveling in
and out of the empire wasn't too
difficult
many traders did so regularly even via
hard borders like hadrian's wall
this ease of travel is why there's so
many roman items and coins found
throughout central eastern and northern
europe
of course in the south of the empire
basically the north african coast in
egypt the southern borders were much
harder to patrol
egypt's southern frontier was one such
difficult border but it did bring great
profits
here the romans had to deal with tribes
like the blembier you may have heard of
them before because the romans believed
that these were a people who didn't have
heads
the romans had a good trading
relationship with the blemish who acted
as intermediaries between rome and the
south of africa but the blemish would
occasionally raid too
perhaps rome's most important border was
that with the parthian later sasani and
persian empire
here the border was a series of
fortifications with many many legions
waiting for any persian invasion but
again people could and did travel
between them
none of what i've told you was stagnant
though rome's borders and the look of
them fluctuated massively over the
centuries until it all came crashing
down
so moving forward over a thousand years
from hadrian we reach the medieval
period and here we'll focus on the
anglo-scottish border formalised in the
1237
treaty of york just to let you know the
anglo-scottish border is not marked by
hadrian's wall the entirety of which
lies in england this may come as a shock
to you but throughout history england
and scotland have not been the best of
friends
the borderlands known as the marches
played host to many a raid or military
campaign over the centuries as both
sides sought to bring the other into a
permanent state of non-existence
during times of peace the two lands had
to co-exist and local lords came to
agreement such as allowing livestock
from either kingdom to graze on each
other's lands that's not to say things
were peaceful bandits or reeves as they
were known would raid across the border
often
in fact the practice of scottish raiders
extorting money from englishman gave
birth to the word blackmail roughly
translated as meaning illicit rent
policing these raids was basically
impossible since there was no government
capable enough to oversee the roughly
100-mile border the law of the land on
both sides was essentially try not to
die and neither the scottish nor the
english crowns were able to do much
about it
needless to say the border between the
two kingdoms in 1237 wasn't simply this
line it was blurred and much of it
wasn't defined by natural barriers
to conclude borders in the modern sense
didn't exist either in theory or in
practice in the ancient or medieval
world
what we think of today as borders those
things which can block individuals from
moving into a political entity simply
weren't feasible a thousand years ago
instead of strict borders there were
frontiers which marked a gradual shift
from one polity to the next
the frontiers were primarily used by
empires or kingdoms to keep out mass
movements i.e
armies instead of individuals and in
that sense they worked quite well
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching and a special
thanks to all of these patrons you see
on screen for their generosity in
supporting the show
and a particularly special thanks to
james bissonette party boyco
michael reynolds gustav swan winston k
wood skye chappelle adam harvey gay
bellary and ozarka flash
you